issue with the
nword and it's fun to sort
of grab that and then use it here or
apply it here in
nonduality because the nword in
nonduality is
nothing it's no
thing to me it's the worst possible
thing
it can
hear is that it's
nothing because me lives in a world of
being
something it lives in a world of not
being everything it lives in a world of
Separation which is non-existent there's
already no
separation
so much love in the live
chat so it's fun to say that nothing or
no is actually the
n-word it's really
fun because it's the most
avoided of
all spiritual words
when the me apparently goes on its
transformative Journey the main word
that it avoids at all costs is
nothing because it wants to grab and
latch onto lots of different concepts
lots of different ideas lots of
different
knowing
teachings
experiences story ARS
gurus all kinds of
knowing and the thing that it avoids at
all costs is
nothing it's is
unknowing the ceasing of grabbing and
boxing conceptualizing
ideating meing
and so nothing or no
everything when there is no entity which
is always already the
case there's
non-locality and there's
obviously no
me and so no thing or nothing is one of
the most direct pointings to being a
non- entity to not being an entity to
not being
local to being everywhere at
once and
so it's
fascinating using the
n-word using nothing as the
n-word and it's quite aggressive to the
sense of me when there's these when
there's this
dualistic
cutting cuz we'll get into some of
that dualistic
cutting here in a
bit and there's one more thing below
that that I won't share
yet there's a comment in the chat
about uh What uh this is saying what
Atlas is saying and what Frank speaking
of Frank Yang are saying and the
question is are these things now
fundamentally different the answer here
the response is they're just pointing to
the same thing but in different
ways
um
the the the coaching uh that Frank does
uh seems to um uh be what
um is
uh uh what is sort of being interfaced
with let's say in a way it's sort of
like there there is
um
um yeah it is it is different in a way
too yeah it's in it's in yeah it is in a
way
um uh it maybe maybe the one of the ways
to say it is that the the coaching that
Frank is doing um or several other of uh
of let's say atlas's close friends um
are um more
uh in a way validating or entertaining
the existence of a me that is on a
transformative journey and then
gradually um
assisting uh the the Seeker with its
transformative process into the
nothingness that it already
is okay it took a bit to say that but
that's that's that's that feels like
what's at the core of it and so this is
just coming from a different place now
it's coming from a more um not
validating the me that's on a
transformative Journey this is coming
from a more um in a way a more radical
um but it's also more uh simple in a way
it's more
ordinary it's um it's it's in a way it's
it's sort of the in a way it's the most
direct way to da it's the most direct
way to the non-local non entiti Unity
that is that can decentralize basic
needs infrastructures be free abundant
playful
joyous
and
yeah there's actually even Beyond um
let's say Alice's close friends there's
even more um spiritual teachers and
teachings and
um uh that's just this appearing as
those spiritual teachers and teachings
that's just nothing appearing as those
spiritual teachers and teachings
and it's unconditional love
unconditional Freedom appearing as that
and so there's
zero um response of this body um to put
any sort of a value uh hierarchy on any
of that um and a lot of that is in a way
it's just teaching knowing in a way so
um part of
the like the the validation of the me
that is on its transformative Journey
that then interfaces with a guru or a
master or a teacher um the guru Master
teacher is usually imparting their
knowing and then me usually uses some
aspect of that knowing to try
to uh deconstruct its tight
binds into the no thingness that it
already is and that's just how that's
appearing and um that's just what is and
then this seems to not entertain um
providing
conceptual um
knowing so instead here instead of
providing conceptual knowing to a me
that is on a transformative journey to
help it deconstruct itself into the no
thingness that it already is what this
is responding more and more nowadays is
that there isn't a me on a
transformative journey and it's already
no
thingness and then it does woof woof
woof
a
meow meow
moo
ribbit ribbit
ribbit
so that has its it's a it's more of
a
uh in a way it's kind of more uh
unknowing it's more immediate it's more
um
um uh colie like
um yeah it's more just not
entertaining the uh dualistic
Fabrications even existing in the first
place thanks for the
question good one to just
clarify
nice there's another comment about um a
glimpse of not having a head yeah we
have that um that is actually coming up
here in a bit um we'll have
that there's some um Harding
headless visuals that we'll bring up to
discuss because they're just simple in a
way they're just really simple and
ordinary ways
of
saying um what always already
is so it's not like a path or a teaching
or something to do or a practice but
it's just simply visual a visual that
just shows the no thing that already
is all right so that was that that first
that first
segment
um
on the new
nword no thing nothing is the new
nword yeah it's fascinating in the
spiritual industrial complex or sick SI
I
the thing that's avoided the most the
nword is nothing it's no
thing because it's just again it's just
most directly pointing to the
non-existence of an
entity to the
non-locality of
everything and that's very uncomfortable
to me and it's very uncomfortable to a
Seeker it's very uncomfortable to that
which wants to know its way to emptiness
because you can't know your way to what
already
is let me say that again you can't know
your way to what already
is you can't experience your way to the
empty
that already
is you can't add Concepts or
attainments to get to the emptiness that
already
is it's already nothing that is
speaking that is
hearing that is watching it's already
nothing
thing it's
non-local it's everything
thinging that's the most simple ordinary
easy way to say or put
it because the ineffable can't be
said and everything that's said is it
cool
so this is this will be fun to see how
much um this sort of saturates the
spiritual industrial complex the
nword it does in a way seem like um
there's some sort of uh burgeoning in a
way in the appearance of the uh n-word
into the the spiritual industrial
complex which is very
fascinating it's fascinating to watch in
the
appearance because it drastically cuts
and
undermines the me that is
solid and attached to its
story
okay yeah yeah we'll we'll uh we'll
perhaps bring some other questions about
in the chats about the food cuz the uh
these are called mukbangs and uh perhaps
we'll bring some uh the food onto it but
the funny thing is is that the the the
reason why it's called that is because
the the concept
that are written here are uh the mukbang
so the um so the the variety of what is
discussed here is the Entre in a way
yeah so that's
what's that's why it's called that and
also just because then it's all um uh
it's all packaged
together into a
um into a like a like a
single
um uh like many different concepts or
many different Entre uh many different
pointings are packaged into the same um
piece of content into the same stream
which is
um it in a way it's just more more
efficient and also it's more
um uh free associative in a
way there's a comment in the live chat
about nothingness feels like free
falling right
and it's it's it's
like there's not an
experiencer that's
experiencing the free falling right so
no me or
emptiness is
so Indescribable it's so simple the
unknowing that's always already here and
it's unboundedly free unboundedly
unspeakably free and
unconditional and so it's just
so it's just you know fresh it's awe
it's peace it's there's no straight
jacket so it's just just easy to just
you know when there's that that
manipulative me energy that's trying to
you know control and and and whatnot the
appearance it's just like and that's
happening there boom cut so so
beautiful yeah that next comment in the
live chat but for no one
exactly
exactly okay so now let's talk about
this me monster so this is another way
to say it so that and that's why in the
quotation marks is in Black because it's
obviously nothing that is me
monstering and that's why it's
non-dual it's not like the me monster is
actually a
reality it's not actually there it's
just a dream it's an illusion to
itself you see it's in its own little
stinky Pond and it's only real to
itself
so there's no Duality because it is just
an illusion it is just real to
itself so nothing is actually what
is appearing as me and that's why it's
non-u that's why it's always nothing
basically it's always nothing it's non
it's always non-local it's always one
it's always that
Singularity and then it can appear as a
contracted me a contracted Center
Point and so that's like a monster it's
like a me monster cuz it's all about
itself it's all about itself and that's
why below you'll see
uh
that uh some of the first three things
that seem to come up about this me
monster there are heess knowingness and
neediness so hear know and
need and that me monster is like mad and
mad in this case is an acronym for
mutually assured
destruction and know me is like Dao
which is a decentralized autonomous
organization and that's why both me and
no me are simply this and there isn't
actually a me so there's only this
there's only
this and that's it's just that that
specific thing is is
like because what can happen is there
can there can become an attachment let's
say to
um uh
to to there being a duality where there
is
none you see that's why this or
isness or appearance or
happening you know this that's why this
Cuts all Duality because
this is the know
me and it's also the ucer of appearance
of
me
and just to speak about this me monster
a little bit more to give some more
detail all you can really do in
nonduality is you can only say what
isn't because you can't say what
is saying what is is like saying the
ineffable how do you say the ocean
how do you say infinity how do you say
everything so you can't actually say
everything it it's not
possible but you can say what's
not
and by saying what's not there's an
undermining of the experience of
Separation which is the only dream the
only
illusion the only dream the only
illusion is the experience of Separation
it's the experience of a mi monster the
experience of a center point that is
here here meaning it's located inside of
a body and that it knows that it's here
it's real it's inside of a body that it
uh is speaking to others that it
experiences
separation that it lacks it
needs and it will find what is missing
through endless varieties of of
pursuit so uh everything from spiritual
seeking trying to find the no thingness
that it already is all the way to
um objects objects and um and
materialism Fame
wealth
clout it will try to find what's missing
and the cosmic joke is nothing is
missing because there isn't a you
there's never been a
you and so that's what that apparent
contracted energy that is a mi monster
that's apparently
what are the
core uh functions is hear knowing
needing and mutually assur destruction
because in that
pursuit of what's not
missing it will do whatever it takes
which
includes uh accumulation of endless uh
uh luxurious
material uh therefore having absolutely
no regard for anything
ecological um it will uh or uh
accumulation of of of wealth and money
and therefore no uh regard whatsoever
for um any sort of ethic or or
morality and then there's um the
mutually sure destruction of the me in
the form of of of nation states and of M
of military industrial complexes and
religions and separation and othering
and having no problem with bombing those
others
um yeah
damn did a whole stream on separation
porn
jeez it's
crazy it really is mutually mutually
sure destruction is the the essence of
of me in addition to uh hear no need and
separation porn is mutually sure
destruction so those are the core let's
say five functions here no need
separation porn and mutually assured
destruction cuz in its Pursuit it just
doesn't care whatsoever what it has to
um to do to get what's not
missing and then know me which is always
already the case is decentralized
autonomous organization it's basic needs
infrastructures it's Freedom Prosperity
abundance for all
it's play Joy music art creativity
science
engineering it's love unconditional love
it's what innocent children and dogs and
cats animals it's what is always already
the case but then is contracted in its
obscuration into a Center Point called
me that lacks and that is
separate
and so obviously again that it's all
this so whether it's uh the body that is
clearly non-local everything or whether
it's the body that is clearly contracted
into me is simply this it's simply this
so there's no Duality there it's just
simply this and then there's an apparent
undermining or a
cutting there's an apparent undermining
or
cutting of the dualisms that the Mi
proliferates so mi will control and
manipulate and grab the appearance and
try to earn validation or try to
proliferate its Concepts project its
Concepts it'll try to um it'll try to uh
to earn validation and earn
worthiness um and it'll go to whatever
extent it needs to to do
so um and it will go into all of those
Pursuits that we discussed earlier
pursuing in um in like luxurious
material and whatnot and so this sort of
Kali energy that cuts the dualism it's
very um and and chops the head is very
um fearlessly uh can uh just responds
with that exact question um that uh you
know
like you know is there is there any
separation you know a question like that
and um you know me will usually struggle
with that question because you know
um or I is anything lacking is another
good one
and um in doing so um or you know are
there others you know and just kind of
like simple easy
questions and those cut or even just a
direct like there isn't a You There Is
No Lack there is no transformative
Journey there are no others there is no
uh geopolitical dispute that is um real
it's all non-separation appearing as
separation
porn so it's just like Cuts Cuts Cuts
Cuts cuts and then these are some of
the some of those
um uh headless let me pull it up
here some of the sort of
pointings about this chopping heads so
this pointing is all about just getting
and this can also you know this is about
not only looking at that image but about
actually just the pointing itself um
with one's own finger
here and then taking that
pointing and looking at the pointer
finger and seeing that it's pointing to
the
nothing that this already is so that's
really the whole thing here is pointing
to what is looking and then what is
looking is
nothing that's this direct
pointing what is
looking is nothing it's no
thing and therefore it is everything
it's non-local it's not an
entity it's unconditional
Freedom unconditional love
and so when you uh when you see that
first one this first image then what you
do is then you see sort of the second
image and the second image is basically
when when there is this pointing and
there's a looking at the finger the
finger's pointing to what's looking and
then what's looking is nothing then
there's a removal of the finger and then
when the finger is removed and then the
the ey
look
out and then they don't fixate so when
the eyes don't
fixate right so normally the eyes are
bouncing they're bouncing constantly
between objects and between thoughts
right this is what is the obsessive
Center disorder that's
happening object object thought thought
thought so when the I
don't fixate when they just rest
okay so the eyes are
resting and they're not
fixating and then what's
seen is that there is only the
scene so there's no
subject
there's just what's
appearing and what's appearing is not
happening
to me it's not happening to an entity
it's not happening to a center
point it's no
thing
appearing and so this visual is what
that that uh sort of that kind of
spacious
aliveness what that
is when there's not a bouncing around
between objects of
fixation and so again it's that what is
hearing what is
looking is
nothing and this sort of this
vastness this
unboundedness this obvious always
free
always without entity without
location
always so this is this is what when when
uh when we write here that it's that
this is chopping heads or cutting
dualism that's sort of what um this is
in a way um referring to it's that what
is looking what is hearing is nothing
it's no thing it's the
nword you it's the thing that's avoided
the most is no thing which is not a
thing because it's
everything
and
that
that um when it says cutting heads and
um chopping heads and cutting
dualism what is being referred to also
is sort of this this um as was mentioned
earlier this obsessive
fixation and objectification
um but also in terms of this head it's
that Center Point that me right me is
Duality and so when there's this when
there's this meanness you
know so this is like meanness in a
way
[Music]
I live in a world of
others I am
real I must find fulfillment I must use
meaning and purpose and will and choice
to navigate in this world of others to
get worthiness and
validation and
wholeness and
fulfillment this is such a such a scary
scary place and uh I have to know
everything I have to I have to have lots
and lots of right and
wrong uh dualistic knowing I must
know and so you see this this thing this
thing
this
is the head you know when we're talking
about cutting cutting the head this is
the head you know and cutting it cutting
it
is
it's always been
perfect this whole
time
yes
everything is
freedom
love
yes and then there's
that I can't believe
is that precious
like the catharsis
that it's just so
precious so precious that unbinding and
unwinding of that me
monster so so precious
thanks fam in the live
chat glad that uh these uh Impressions
and silliness has been uh creating that
LMAO Vibe and
fun yeah same I'm so excited for all
these weird
spontaneous
joyful uh playful sessions and whatever
arises
oh so all right and now let's uh let's
wrap up with the
nice uh the one that I haven't showed
it's the only it's the only um one in
the mukbang that I haven't showed yet
and here it
is all right so this one is dsm6 a new
view and I use the word view but it's
not it's not really a view but I just
couldn't think of anything better so I
just wrote a new view but for those that
don't know I'll go ahead and bring up um
what the just a brief
uh definition of of the DSM so this is a
the diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders that's what the DSM is
and it's the handbook used by Health
Care Professionals in the United States
and much of the world as the
authoritative Guide to the
diagnosis of mental
disorders so DSM contains descriptions
symptoms and other criteria for
diagnosing mental disorders
right
so so in essence this Diagnostic and
statistical Manual of mental
disorders it's currently on its fifth or
so version it's not yet into its sixth
version and each version is obviously
updated and this uh like American
Psychiatric association and these uh
healthc Care Professionals across the
world are uh working together in many
ways to update this authoritative guide
to mental disorders and so as we've been
playfully saying on the show uh that OCD
is actually this obsessive centered
disorder you know as another way to say
the
acronym um in a way um what's being um
said what's being is really just a
response it's not it's not the
appearance should be this way cuz the
appearance is obviously already perfect
and free but this is just a this is just
a simple response of the body to the
appearance which is that the DSM the
entire Diagnostic and statistical manual
all of this
psychiatric literature across
earth all of it and all these healthc
Care Professionals that are
authoritative guides on mental
disorders all of it is coming from the
place of me it's all coming from the
place of self it's coming from the place
of an existent
entity so basically what it does is it
assumes the existence of
Separation so the current
DSM assumes the existence of
separation and then all of
the an analysis of what's going on in
the world of me in relation to
others and my mental
disorders in a world of
others that's where the authoritative
guide makes its suggestions and
recommendations from so the DSM itself
makes its suggestion
from the center point from the
perspective of the center
point which is
non-existent so what is being suggested
as just a
response right is that this new
view for the dsm6 for the for where new
Earth's potential psych psych Psychiatry
can head is is in the direction of
instead of instead of having the uh
authoritative guide on mental disorders
be from the perspective of the center
point in a world of others so assuming
separation instead of that it can be
from the perspective of nonseparation
which is not really a view it's not
really a perspective it's actually like
the absence of perspective it's the
absence of view which is why there was
that struggling with saying a New View
CU it's really the absence of view in a
way
um and
so the response is that by having this
let's say dsm6 from the uh from
the from from
non-separation what is uh what's obvious
is that then what is uh the uh the
diagnosis and the recommendation that
are happening from a center point in a
world of others which so much of the
time in involve or include uh uh some
sort of prescriptions so not only like
drugs so the pharmaceutical industrial
complex uh pick p i pharmaceutical
industrial complex gets
involved so you see six spiritual
industrial complex the psychiatric
industrial complex the therapeutical
industrial complex the transformation
industrial complex the pharmaceutical
industrial complex all of these things
are in a tight ass yarn ball that's full
of
knots and
so when those
recommendations are being made these
diagnoses of mental disorders are being
made from the perspective of a center
point in a world of
others instead of using the n-word I
don't even know if the nword of nothing
is even in the DSM 5 is even in any of
the uh psychiatric
literature in some ways it appeared like
there was an inclusion of of some um
slightly mystical things but
it's uh the
there let's say it it would need to it
would it would it would it would it
would be it would have to turn itself
Inside Out is another way to say it in
order for
um this sort of dsm6 to be from the from
um
the from the non-separation from the
wholeness from the no thingness that
always is so how can another way to say
is how can a
psychiatrist how can a
psychologist how can
uh a
therapist how can a even a priest or a
shaman or a
monk How can there
be a a a a
recommendation when it's coming from a
center point to another Center Point
from a me to another
me so all of
the DSM
literature all of
the
transformational uh experiences and
industrial complex it's all about from a
center point to another Center Point now
there are certain examples of there
being um
uh uh
very very empty and clear
um just non-u cutting of that illusion
of me but this is where this sort of um
dsm6 and New View would would go it
would go it would go into the what is um
always already not separate always
already non- entity and that's a very um
that's the that's the opposite of
Separation porn in a way there are no
opposites but that's the opposite of
Separation
porn so right now the DSM in a way it
exacerbates separation porn so uh and
there's a whole industrial complex
around exacerbating separation porn
including uh the media industrial
complex the military industrial complex
the transformational industrial complex
spiritual industrial complex
pharmaceutical industrial
complex and these uh psychiatrists and
um and these different therapists these
different um teachers or guides um are
are reading this DSM
literature and then as a me they're
acquiring these this knowledge and these
Concepts and then they're talking to
another assumed Center
Point and they're imparting this
knowledge and these concepts for this me
to be on its transformational
journey and so that's what the current
Paradigm of of
uh of Diagnostic and statistical Manual
of mental disorders the authoritative
guide to diagnosing mental disorders is
coming from this
place
so that's very fascinating um sort of
like where it's currently um coming
from where it's currently coming from
and where it can come
from because by coming from this is also
fascinating by let's say by
dsm6 let's say coming from the place of
of nonseparation
um what
happens is this this uh the the the me
monster is is
cut and this sort of this non-entity
non-local um Harmony of basic needs
infrastructures and DOW of abundance for
all basic needs for all joy love
prosperity all of that can
actually um just
gorgeously um
just
yeah
and
the there was there's just a question uh
in the chat briefly what is a question a
question is just nothing
questioning um and that's all that's
always fascinating because it's always
nothing that is asking the questions
it's always nothing that is hearing or
watching it's always that it's never a
me it's never an entity it's never a
center point it's never actually that
and that's why it's non- du because it's
always already
nothing always already nothing
that's why it's nonu so all of all of
non-duality is just cutting the ucer
existence of a me which isn't actually
there
yay yes uh the comment in the chat also
about uh sounds like Shambala to me yes
that's exactly it um so
um in a way um you can say that
through through um through um
clearly
um through the
n-word clearly saturating the appearance
which it's it's already the case but
there's the appearance of so many of
these contracted Center
points through the nword saturating the
appearance
that's Shambala
manifest that's how dawing basic needs
and prosperity that's how all of
the you know we we've we've brought this
up we've brought this up on the show
um
quite a bit but the sort of
um in a way it's like some sort of yeah
like kind of solar punk futurism in a
way but it's just an absolute and this
is just again these are just uh to be
clear these are just uh visuals this is
this is not a guiding flow of any sort
um because it's all just absolutely
mysterious in how this sort of uh da SL
Shambala is all um uh will how it will
appear
but um the sort of the sort of things
that are that are possible from uh from
what is clearly uh
non-separation is uh is just
unbelievable and what is like free
energy right so it's just it's just a
complete joke that um in a way it's a
complete Cosmic joke that um that uh
free that free energy free food free
water free housing um free
wellness it's a joke that that is not
already the case so the cosmic joke in a
way is that um there is a
matrix that um is entered into to uh
sell the appear of body time for uh for
money um to pay for basic needs like
water food housing energy
Wellness so that's in a way that is the
cosmic that is also the cosmic joke so
anyway this is this is the kind of stuff
that this is sort of the frequency in a
way that or the vibration to um to kind
of be tuned into because this is what is
possible
when
um when the when the when the nword
saturates the appearance and unbinds or
unwinds those illusions of me centerp
pointing lacking and madting so that me
monster is all about here it's about
knowing it's about
needing and hearing is the opposite of
non-locality in a way there is no real
opposite but it's like
non-local uh contracted into a Center
Point called
here and
then so as the nword as nothing
saturates the appearance and unbinds
unwinds those ucer mes the mutually
assured destruction Vibe all of this in
cultured This World War II separation
porn it's all just separation porn all
of that unwinds and
unbinds and the know me nature of Dao of
Shambala of basic needs being met
abundance play
yay that becomes more and more what is
apparent and again there's no Duality
between no me and me it's always already
this always already this just
this simply this only
this right so
this already nothing everything which
includes that contracted illusion of
me so
simple nothing ever everything
including that contracted appearance of
me it's always already that which is
this and there's nowhere to go from
there that's
it and
so
by this colie this Fearless cutting of
dualism and chopping heads that's how
these these elusory contracted Center
points that are that are mutually
assured
destruction that those unbind unwind
into Dow into Shambala
in and this uh New View on uh Diagnostic
and statistical manual and of uh how to
uh diagnose and treat mental disorders
not from the perspective of
Separation but from the perspective
which is perspectiv lessness of
nonseparation of non-
Entin you know imagine the that
contracted me comes to that the
psychiatrist therapist healer whatever
um and you know the the response is that
there there isn't actually a you the
story itself is
unreal you can relax there's only the
whole there's only unconditional love
and
freedom there's only everything there's
only
that and you can see that that there's a
huge difference between that and okay so
now yeah let's uh yeah so obviously
you're struggling a lot and um you know
uh obviously you have a very very hard
life and um yeah and you have uh such a
complex story it's like validating the
complex story so there's a validation of
the complexity of the story and then
there's a pummeling with suggestions or
Transformations it's like no you're not
already whole you're not already free
and this is the path this is what you
have to do this is how you have to
transform yourself these are the the uh
pharmaceutical drugs that you have to
take in order for you to be free in
order for you to be
whole and so that's what um is uh in a
way it
promulgates uh that
contraction and um what what's being
suggested with the possibility of
dsm6 is this sort of um coming from
what's already free what's already whole
what's already non- entity and non-local
what's already unconditional
love and just how much different would
it be for that sense of contracted me to
have that kind of a of an of a
interaction where that no thingness is
directly pointed to and that that me
can have have that that like we did
earlier can have
that
it's all already
perfect already
whole and there's lots of perverse um
Financial incentives that are in that
um that um psychiatric industrial
complex and transformative industrial
complex spiritual industrial complex
pharmaceutical industrial complex
there's a lot of perverse Financial
incentives that are
there and so obviously if the reflection
is like colie where it's Cuts The
Duality and that me
just
wow then that is
done
so where's the financial incentive
there's
none there's no Financial
incentive there's no Financial incentive
in the
n-word it's another fun way to say it
there's no Financial incentive in the
nword there's no
illusion promulgation in the
nword the nword is just direct immediate
freedom and so it just undermines all of
the
perverse Financial incentives of those
industrial
complexes
and it undermines the Seeker on its wild
complex transformative Journey it
undermines the me monster on
its on its Journey towards of hear
knowing lacking towards mutually sure
destruction and
just bless this uh this nword
man bless this
nword it's so
beautiful and
the these really
simple easy
pointings
ah this is
nothing
whoa
unfix there's no
subject there's only the
scene there's only what's appearing
that's nothing that's Freedom that's
holess that's
love fulfillment is
always been here
baby yeah
[Music]
yeah you know this dance potties uh
the dance potties of
fulfillment always already being
here and
everywhere the dance party of
fulfillment what what dance party of
whole
this dance poty
freom dance dance dance dance dance
dance dance dance dance dance dance
dance dance dance dance
dance
Freedom always and
already
we all right thanks for joining the
mukang I the
mukbang thanks for
enjoying
whatever these Concepts and free
association and no
thinging thanks for joining in the live
chat
and as
always infinite
love thank you
yeah I'm
excited will likely bring together the
Community here in Austin Texas at some
point currently we're considering um a
summer of
24 and
um 2024 so some
like and bringing together simulation
Community but also home Dow community so
yeah bringing together the basic needs
infrastructures developers and
apparently there's a nearly a thousand
people that are moving to Austin every
single day which is crazy if there's
actually over 300,000 people moving to
Austin every
year um and so there's a lot of uh new
infrastructure that can be developed
that are like that are that are Shambala
like and this is what we're really
excited about and also bringing together
the simulation community to just have so
much fun so much Shenanigans so much
silly play so much
nording
oh yes yes so
exciting so much of that unconditional
love and
freedom
so Al
righty uh we'll probably
stream again later today and see you
then